from the daily wire it says
representative alexandra queza cortez
lashed out at critics on friday after
she was caught hanging out in miami
florida as her city deals with a
record-breaking number of daily
chronovirus cases national review
reported that according to photographs
obtained by the publication cortez was
seated outside
in miami beach
and uh she was drinking a cocktail she
didn't have a mask on
and she responded to one of her critics
calling her out saying if republicans
are mad they can't date me they can just
say that instead of projecting their
sexual frustrations onto my boyfriend's
feet i guess cause someone made a
comment about the fact that her
boyfriend has ugly feet which it seems
like he does
um then she said you creepy weirdos
and she continued
it's starting to get old ignoring the
very obvious strange and deranged sexual
frustrations
that underpin the republican fixation on
me women and lgbt plus people in general
these people clearly need therapy they
won't do it and they use politics as
their outlet instead it's really weird
and this actually prompted this is a
whole
day-long meltdown on aoc's part
where she was insisting that everyone
who criticizes her is actually sexually
attracted to her
and this this stems from two things
number one she is a uh
a very very stupid person
and i certainly don't say that about
everybody on the left i think there are
plenty of
smart people on the left evil
evil but but intelligent
um in the democrat party as well
unfortunately
but that's not the case for her she's
very very stupid and she's not able to
engage intellectually
with any point that anybody makes
and so she retreats to the common thing
which is to just
label
if you can't engage with an argument
then you simply you label it
and usually we're gonna uh it's
homophobic it's transphobic and sexist
and in this case also it's it's it's an
expression of your
deep-seated sexual frustrations
and there's a lot of projection that
goes into that as well
now people on the left they see they see
sexual frustration everywhere they go
in the that is supposedly driving the
behavior of everyone around them
but all we can assume based on that is
that that is that's their own experience
that's how they operate and so they
assume that everyone else operates the
same way
so there's that there's there's
projection there's stupidity and there's
also simply a narcissism
you know she she
assumes again that everyone is sexually
attracted to her and so
anytime anyone talks to her says
anything about her it must be fueled by
that
narcissistic shallow and uh
and that's what you get from aoc
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated